in midair Johnson tape to tape to Captain
Kyle aoso a blocker sto byar samuelon along
the line Owen power blocked in the
high slot power to samel gets through
makoy and cross the Zone Thea tape to
tape to Jeff Skinner and blocker saved
by Omar Thomson powers out of the corner
middle stat off coil stick coil a lunging
swipe march on to the corner C steals
from power and throws it on Levi try
to bank it in off him behind the goal
L poock with his ears pinned back and a
glove save by Levi having a productive
season here's Pera his shot muffled by
makoy Cy tosses it through the corner pav
zaka gives it away to PKA in the middle of
the defensive Zone Eric Johnson a blocker saved
by Omar and it just sits there Zach Benson misses
the goal or if it was a saber that hit that puck
I thought it was M trying to get possession for
his go Tyson jooss the middle Yoki Haru a wrist
shot a rebound andark denies olon that's a nice
left pad save van re D toi Goes Around the
Net and a spinning backand by Van Reams Dy
draft pick Robinson used to play for the Columbus
Blue Jackets tosses to makoy the puck exploded on
him Tage Thompson the rang Center gets Chinese
muster down that drop pass comes out to Center
fli fires away Mar BLS it Saka cut back stolen by
cousins Turka goes left back hands it off debrus
gets it back slot Benson PKA closes a rebound
goes into the circle and pck takes it out the
off the end wall Saka tries to Center Oscar steam
checked from behind by Vi olon Ryan Johnson the
defenseman Casey middle stat on the elbow power
fires away and a glove save byar Robinson picks
it off power pushes the pace and a great
toes save by olark denying aoso a leg save
and there's a scramble in the crease and no
goal br's getting out shot by more than a 4
to one ratio Samson Sav by omark and a semi
break for Heen toasts up in the slot power
to cousin a shot and a save by olark poock gets
his skates underneath grizzli Locker stopped by
Levi Yoki Haru centers and PKA saved by
Omar Saka one for three at the dot and one for
four and PKA scores continuing his hot streak
now 18 points in his last 20 games yeah I
don't know if this Puck is just one that
Omar can't pick up I can't tell if it's you
know through Benson and he can't see it until
it's morai skates it out hits Kiki a save by
Levi clipon gets the jump and Olson Heen
well olark came out to play the puck a
deflection in front by Benson Charlie makoy
makoy to zaka Deus on the net Drive poock
fires away and Leo by makes a save can
find zaka through the neutral zone now
you got a little something going off the
rush march on to lindol loose in front
and Ryan Johnson clears lindle passs
to Carlo one timer and Levi makes the
stop Saka wins the draw poock partially
deflected and slowed down for Levi tap
to tape to beer and Oscar Ste has
a break and it's off the glove and
off the outside of the post and geeki
wins the draw Clifton to Thompson and he
scores Tage Thompson has a fearsome one
timer V Rees I can't allow that play to
happen you got to be on the same page
with Lindholm who's making the play up
the wall and it allows Clifton to carry
that puck in by the hash mark and you
can see all the black jerseys around
him that means somebody's going to be
open around the boards Maran in the circle
and throw the puck out of the net five in a
row for Maran yeah little ker there working
for Brad Marshon given what he was dealing
with and his personal situation good keep
in by Carlo another wrap around this time
it's going to be lyol back around the
wall Maron takes a good angle to that
puck he's looking to make a play across
the ice to Charlie Cole it's going to
deflect spins around middle stat goes
the other way Carlo went for the Poke
check two onone Skinner and Thompson and
Omar holds the short side Kiki laai a save
by Levi bouncing around the the slot and
it bounced over Kiki stick two onone olon
scores
they bent over backwards but would
not break guys in and around the
offensive net and the puck squirts
out it's going to be numbers in the
opposite direction it's the second
two-on one during this uh continuous
play sequence the first one gets off the
schneide Levi another save at the siren